au fond de cet atelier à
savigny-sur-orge quatre artisans se
concentre sur une surprenante création
[Musique]
l'atelier flore et brice et pour la
broderie
les deux frères de l'atelier thierry
pour la dorure et la chocolaterie à la
reine astrid pour le chocolat ce trio de
maisons d'artisanat s'est unie pour
créer une robe en chocolat qui défilera
au 25e salon du chocolat de paris à la
base flore hybris est designer textile
c'est elle qui a imaginé et fabriqué de
la structure de la môme général la
broderie ouvre le trail de dorure à la
feuille sont les éléments décoratifs qui
sont ajoutés par dessus le vêtement ou
l'élément décoratif ici c'est ce travail
là qui est mis en avant en une élément
structurel d'une certaine manière le
plastron en plastique et donc prod et il
a nécessité 80 des heures de travail
avant de pouvoir être recouverts de
chocolat donc là voilà une petite couche
de vernis nicolas morin s'occupe du
chocolat pour s'assurer qu'il se
maintienne
il applique une couche de vernis puis du
chocolat brut
une deuxième couche de vernis et termine
avec de la poudre de cacao pour donner
une texture à la robe dont le chocolat
il faut qu'il soit comme à ses fins
finalement parce que s'il est trop épais
et si on applique de manière trop
épaisse risque de se passer qu'avec son
propre poids et avec les mouvements
qu'il y aura du coup au moment du défilé
barça se décolle pour mettre en valeur
le travail de broderie les frères
thierry s'occupe de la dorure en savoir
faire familial autres en sont membres
depuis dix ans tous les deux et notre
sort nous a rejoint tout récemment
tous deux se relaient pour appliquer la
colle puis déposez les feuilles d'or un
matériau très fins qui ne peut être pris
à la main et nécessitent l'utilisation
d'une palette en poils de martre c'est
pas ces pratiques que son ombre on verra
c'est pour graisser un peu la palette on
peut la placer sur les cheveux ou par un
petit peu les tristes et statique la
baisse un peu et c'est pour pouvoir
attraper la feuille relativement
facilement mais ont butté viendra
s'ajouter une jupe drapée tout en
souplesse et les doreurs ornements trop
la peau d'elizabeth tchoungui la
journaliste franco camerounaise choisi
pour porter la robe
ça fait longtemps que j'ai envie de
faire défiler une robe au salon du
chocolat est en fait mon engagement au
cameroun depuis quelques années fait que
tout naturellement s'est dit que ça
serait sympa de faire un truc qui tourne
aussi autour du cameroun la robe
défilera au milieu de 22 autres lors de
la soirée inaugurale du salon du
chocolat le 29 octobre
quant à la chocolaterie de la reine
astrid vous pouvez la retrouver tout le
long du salon stand des 42